[HIP-HOP MUSIC PLAYING]
LORENZO LAING: I like hip-hop,
because it reminds me of where
I'm from -- New York City.
While one, it can be fun,
it has a great beat that I
like to dance to, it also
is reflective of a lot
of societal issues, and
it brings the two together
in a really unique way
that I really appreciate,
and I haven't really
found in another genre.
My name is Lorenzo
Laing, and I'm
a senior in the Class
of 2016, and I'm
a sociology major with a
certificate in American studies.
[HIP-HOP MUSIC]
So my thesis is on the
re-appropriation of rap music
by queer artists of color.
So I'm looking at how a small
group of recently emerging
artists have
incorporated themselves
into a historically
homophobic genre, and one
that still maintains a
hetero-normative structure
in the mainstream.
I think hip-hop dance very
much influenced my decision
to become a sociology
major, because I understand
that hip-hop music
can be problematic,
and that those problems aren't
necessarily justifiable.
But sociology has taught
me that those problems
can be explained.
In doing so, we go beyond
superficial understandings
that can be potentially
dangerous of the genre,
and of the people who make
the music and consume it.
In terms of my thesis,
I guess I've just
been looking at some more
literature related to the ones
that I had looked at before,
just looking at general themes
like re-appropriation
and appropriation,
kind of in a historical context.
CAROL STACK: And are we still
hopeless about actually
getting to interview
some of these people?
LORENZO LAING: Luckily,
I got IRB approval
during our last meeting,
so I have approval to do that.
Before Princeton, I had done
sports for most of my life.
But before I got
to college, I knew
that I wanted to do
something different,
and I didn't necessarily
know what that would be.
But when I got to
Princeton Preview
and I saw the Black
Arts Dance Company,
I knew that that was it, and
I auditioned my freshman fall,
and I've been a
member ever since.
What I appreciate about
BAC is that we're really
a tight-knit group.
We're also a pretty
diverse group,
and it's introduced me to
people that I might not
have met otherwise.
So while I'm a social
sciences major,
I never really venture into
the engineering part of campus,
but there are a lot
of engineers in BAC,
and a lot of
different class years.
So in that way, BAC brings a lot
of different people together.
Our friendship goes
beyond the dance studio,
so we'll hang out
together, we'll
help each other with
homework, and we'll just
be there for each other.
And then my dance company has
kept me sane, essentially,
for the past four years.
And I can't imagine
what the experience
would be without them.
[SINGING]